hammerfest the self-styled northernmost
city in the world with the weather to
match
this arctic town is the gateway to the
oil industry in the barren sea one of
the sources of norway's 1.1 trillion
dollar sovereign wealth fund
here engineers groove threads into pipes
that must be accurate to 1 500 of a
millimeter to avoid catastrophic leaks
when drilling for oil and gas
the meaning of oil in norway's is
essential this is what we have built in
over 50 years in norway this is a this
is making norway norway we will develop
this business also to go more and more
green but still we are dependent of oil
the giant rig goliath was towed north
from hammerfest but it may be one of the
last this year norway offered up
licenses to explore for oil in eight new
areas in the barrens and one in the
north sea
only four of them were taken up
firms like the state oil company ecuanor
are still plugging away in the barren
sea despite having drilled a number of
dry wells in recent years but the
apparent general lack of interest in
exploring this part of the continental
shelf comes as the norwegian people seem
to be just starting to turn away from an
industry that transformed their country
from one of the poorest in europe to one
of the richest in the world
with an election looming the greens who
want to end all exploration look like
getting enough votes to make them king
makers in a coalition the government has
responded by reducing how much taxpayers
will subsidise new drilling we still
have a long-term view on the activity on
the norwegian continental shelf but
having said that we are preparing for a
future with less demand and also less
production in fact we do predict that
norwegian oil production will perhaps go
down by as much as 65 percent towards
the middle of the century and that's
simply because the norwegian continental
shelf is mature and we're probably well
above the peak now
norway's past and present come together
in hammerfest fishing and reindeer
herding continues a few miles from
ecuador's liquid nitrogen gas plant
but it's the future that's in focus in
this camp where indigenous activist
lasse bjorn is one of six
environmentalists who have taken norway
to the european court of human rights
over its drilling in the arctic
hopefully it will have serious
consequences of norwegian oil policy
we'll have hopefully have a government
that takes
into account that norwegian oil policy
are causing climate change what are we
if we lose our areas our nature
less speculation in the barrance may be
welcomed by an increasing number of
voters but existing norwegian fields
still pump out 4 million barrels of oil
a day with norway's economy and its
generous benefits reliant on that
production change to greener energy will
only come about slowly paul reese al
jazeera hammerfest